would you fight it  uh well his record goes back way before  the Federation even existed he was a  major in the United us military assault  command operation lot of offworld combat  he was a soldier why has he not used his  weapon it he wants to find somewhere to  inflict maximum damage click on the  planet  he needs a distribution deal heezy  we need a distribution deal oh we have  one he needs a three-picture deal worse  than I've ever heard link oh yeah my  name is James Tiberius Kirk of the  United Federation of Planets I'm  appearing before you as a neutral  representative of the feminine but fo  Bowen fuh Bonin I'm appearing before you  as a neutral representative of the fab  anona  as a neutral representative of the FO  Bonin gotten to us oh they're happy  I must represent some  there's some sort of future global  transport friendly lieutenant there's  sorry weird noises up this isn't the  last of my crew but this is my last  report as the captain